now in other news Iraq's Air Force says
it has killed several top Islamic state
commanders in an airstrike but has
admitted that initial claims the group's
leader also died may be incorrect the
Iraqi military says it hit a convoy of
cars carrying Abu Bakr al-baghdadi on
his way to a meeting in Anbar province
that is near Iraq's border with Syria
hospital officials say that although at
least eight senior eius leaders were
killed in the attack al Baghdadi was not
among the dead the Iraqi military says
they believe he was driven away from the
scene of the attack and that his fate is
unknown
an Israeli Arab has stabbed and wounded
four people at a bus stop in northern
Israel police say the man rammed his car
into a woman before getting out of his
vehicle and stabbing her he then stabbed
three other people nearby including an
army conscript who's reported to be in a
serious condition
well the stabbing attack came at the end
of a day of clashes between Palestinian
youths and Israeli forces in cities
across the West Bank the ongoing
protests and the continuing lone wolf
attacks on Israeli Jews are heightening
tensions over Jewish access to the
Temple Mount where the al-aqsa mosque is
situated for Israelis and 23
Palestinians have died in 12 days of
bloodshed so far yesterday hundreds of
people attended the funeral of a
Palestinian man who was shot during
clashes with Israeli forces last
Thursday and who died of his wounds on
Saturday there was more violence between
Palestinian protesters and Israeli
soldiers following the funeral tires
were set alight
some of the protesters threw homemade
Molotov cocktails towards the soldiers
who sprayed them with skunk water and
fired tear grass teargas grenades in
Gaza the funerals were held of three
Palestinians whom officials say were
killed in an Israeli air strike
including a pregnant woman and her
three-year-old daughter
Israel says it carried out two attacks
on Hamas weapons factories and that was
in response to cross-border rocket fire
medical officials in Gaza say the woman
and her daughter were killed when their
house collapsed during one of the air
strikes will earlier we spoke to The
Jerusalem Post reporter Daniel
but at the moment it's a market
escalation there's no question about it
there were a number of riots over the
weekend by the border fence and several
Palestinians were killed during the
rioting when they attacked IDF soldiers
manning the defense and this is also
part of the rioting that's going on in
Jerusalem and in the West Bank
so no region in this area has been
spared riots over the last two weeks and
it has indeed escalated to a dangerous
looming Sunday that lordose Palestinian
casualties by an Israeli airstrike since
the ceasefire was called during last
year's war in Gaza there are three
players involved in this right now
they include the Palestinian Authority a
mosque and the northern branch of the
Islamic movement which is also a
fundamentalist and violent organization
all these groups have one thing in
common and that is that they are falsely
claiming that Israel intends to see
these al-aqsa mosque which is perhaps
the hottest cottony compress in this
conflict and this has resulted in
numerous lone wolf terrorist attacks
mostly carried out with knives but the
latest terrorist attacks that placed in
hadera located in northern Israel your
hypothesis when a Palestinian man drove
his vehicle into a female soldier and
then stabbed three other victims the
suspect was arrested is being questioned
by the police while the four Israeli
victims have been compromised in our
serious condition and this is the
problem of the conflict not the majority
of the people involved in it who are
mostly peaceful it's a fringe element
that's extremely violent represented by
groups like Hamas that do not want peace
do not want to recognize Israel under
any circumstance and until there is some
kind of
agreement that Israel has the right to
exist that Jews have a right to exist I
don't foresee a peaceful coexistence